aid agencies say an estimated 40 000
children are trapped in the el hall and
raj refugee camps in northeast syria
every day is a struggle for survival and
the statistics tell a grim story save
the children says at least two have died
every week since the start of the year
some were killed from avoidable
illnesses others by fires poor
sanitation malnutrition and even murder
living conditions are tough and daily
outbreaks of violence are making them
worse
they're witnessing so much
trauma around them they're living
through it every day
and we're really concerned about what
this means for children growing up in
these conditions it's simply no place
for a child to grow up and so we're
calling strongly on governments to
repatriate their children bring them
back to their countries and give them a
chance for a proper life
calls to repatriate the foreign
nationals among the camp's 60 000
residents are not new at least 30 000
are from iraq and 10 000 are from other
countries many are families of isil
fighters or those who lived under their
control before the armed group was
defeated in the region three years ago
some countries have taken back their
citizens but many have not
since 2017 nearly 1200 children have
been repatriated almost 59 percent of
them went home in 2019
but repatriations declined in 2020 and
so far this year there have been only
14.
the united nations is calling for action
from the nearly 60 governments who are
believed to have nationals in the camps
but with differences on policy possible
security threats and the lack of
political will many are reluctant each
of those countries have their own local
situation with
their own complexities in terms of the
political environment so this is
something that each government is having
to to work through as they consider the
repetition of their nationals the second
level i would say is the legal one and
so in many countries as well there are
complexities in terms of the actual
nationality of these children
and mothers
eighty percent of the camp's residents
are women and children sixty-five
percent of them are under the age of 18.
they're vulnerable not just to the dire
conditions but also to the threat of
radicalization in camps described as the
most dangerous in the world and with the
slow pace of repatriations it will take
decades before they can leave